À quelle vitesse vivez-vous ?
Nous ne vivons pas tous à la même vitesse.
Certains vivent, ou tout du moins nous donnent
l’impression de vivre plus de choses en
moins de temps.
Beaumarchais, le célèbre dramaturge du XVIIIe
siècle, l’auteur de la devise du quotidien
Le Figaro — Beaumarchais qui était aussi
un aventurier, a dit :
« Si le temps se mesure par les événements
qui le remplissent, j'ai vécu deux cents
ans.
»
Idriss Aberkane lui aussi, semble-t-il, ne
vit pas à la même vitesse que nous.
Alors qu’il a seulement la trentaine, il
a déjà multiplié les diplômes, les jobs,
les projets entrepreneuriaux ou humanitaires,
les apparitions médiatiques, les œuvres
(et je ne connais pas sa vie amoureuse).
Il a vécu dans plusieurs pays ; donné des
centaines de conférences ; publié plus d’une
centaine de vidéos sur YouTube ; écrit des
essais, des poèmes, et des chansons de rap.
À moins de la moitié de sa vie, il a déjà
appris et accompli ce que l’homme ordinaire
ne pourrait apprendre ni accomplir, lui, en
plusieurs vies.
Il nous donne l’impression d’être, pour
reprendre l’expression de Beaumarchais,
un homme de deux cents ans…
tout particulièrement sur le plan de la culture
générale.
En la matière, comme pour le reste, on peut
estimer qu’il triche.
Ou bien on peut penser qu’il a des secrets…
Idriss Aberkane est un personnage controversé,
donc je commence par un disclaimer.
Cette vidéo n’est pas un éloge d’Idriss
Aberkane, donc si vous ne l’aimez pas, écoutez-moi
jusqu’au bout ; cette vidéo n’est pas
non plus une critique d’Idriss Aberkane,
donc si vous l’aimez bien, écoutez-moi
jusqu’au bout.
Mon but n’est pas de déterminer si Idriss
Aberkane est honnête ou malhonnête, s’il
a tort ou raison (ou plutôt dans quelle mesure
il a tort ou raison).
Mon but est de découvrir comment il s’y
est pris pour développer si rapidement une
si grande culture générale, et de vous aider
à vous inspirer de ses méthodes pour enrichir
efficacement votre propre culture générale,
et ainsi mieux comprendre le monde.
Cela vous sera utile quelle que soit votre
opinion d’Idriss Aberkane (c’était déjà
vrai pour Jacques Attali, le modèle de ma
précédente vidéo).
Vous pouvez me dire ce que vous pensez d’Idriss
Aberkane dans les commentaires, mais s’il
vous plaît, gardez en tête l’objet de
la vidéo, et ne cherchez pas à me ranger
dans le camp des partisans ni dans celui des
détracteurs — ce n’est pas ma guerre,
comme a dit Rambo.
Qui est Idriss Aberkane ?
C’est un Français qui aura 36 ans dans
quelques jours.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, il a fait beaucoup
de choses et il a plusieurs casquettes — mais
pour faire simple, il est surtout connu comme
conférencier et écrivain.
Il a émergé dans l’espace médiatique
français grâce au succès de son essai Libérez
votre cerveau ! (sorti fin 2016).
Il a lancé sa chaîne YouTube il y a 2 ans,
et elle a connu un succès qui me paraît
rapide — je ne suis pas un expert de YouTube
— jusqu’à dépasser le demi million d’abonnés.
Après, Idriss Aberkane suscite la controverse
— et cela essentiellement pour deux raisons.
Tout d’abord, on l’accuse d’avoir gonflé
son CV ; et ensuite, il a pris position contre
les politiques de gestion de la pandémie
de Covid-19.
Je n’évoquerai pas ces controverses, car
ce n’est pas le sujet de la vidéo.
Si j’ai choisi de m’intéresser à Idriss
Aberkane, c’est parce que, comme il l’affirme
lui-même sur son site, « il est passionné
par le savoir et la manière dont il se transmet
».
Étant donné qu’il est jeune — et donc
qu’il n’existe pas de biographie d’Idriss
Aberkane — et étant donné que je ne le
connais pas personnellement, j’ai fait de
la « rétro-ingénierie » pour trouver les
principes qui lui ont permis d’acquérir
sa grande culture générale : j’ai lu ses
trois livres ; j’ai regardé la plupart
de ses vidéos YouTube, la plupart de ses
conférences, de ses interviews, et également
sa masterclass sur MentorShow (dont le titre
me laissait penser que je pourrais y trouver
des informations intéressantes pour mon script).
Vous, vous allez économiser tout ce travail,
parce que je vais vous révéler les 3 secrets
de la culture générale d’Idriss Aberkane.
Et puis pour chaque secret, je vous dirai
également comment vous pouvez l’appliquer
concrètement.
Regardez donc attentivement cette vidéo jusqu’au
bout, et vous saurez enrichir votre cuture
générale bien plus efficacement.
Faut-il se doper pour se cultiver ?
On peut être tenté, parce que rester concentré,
accorder durablement son attention — par
exemple à un livre ou à un conférencier
— cela n’a rien de naturel.
On ne nous en parle pas à l’école, mais
la stimulation des performances intellectuelles
est une pratique ancienne chez les artistes
et les écrivains.
Au XXe siècle, les progrès de la chimie
ont multiplié les solutions, et depuis la
fin des Trente Glorieuses, l’usage de certains
stimulants s’est banalisé dans des milieux
professionnels compétitifs comme la finance,
la télévision, ou… la politique.
Le film Limitless a popularisé le fantasme
d’une superintelligence artificielle.
Une petite pilule de NZT, et nous nous souvenons
de tout ce que que nous avons lu ; nous réfléchissons
à 100 à l’heure ; nous apprenons des langues
en faisant notre footing ; et nous pouvons
écrire un roman à succès en une nuit.
Idriss Aberkane a des petites pilules magiques,
c’est ça son secret ?
Non non, ce n’est pas ça.
Son 1er secret découle de son analyse de
la stimulation artificielle des performances
intellectuelles dans un milieu particulier
: pas chez les financiers ni chez les stars
du show-biz — mais à l’école et à l’université.
En effet, depuis la fin du XXe siècle, des
adolescents, et même des enfants se font
diagnostiquer des troubles de l’attention,
puis prescrire — souvent avec l’aval,
voire à l’initiative des parents — des
psychostimulants comme de l’Adderall ou
de la Ritaline, qui permettent de rester concentrés
de longues heures.
C’est un phénomène préoccupant aux États-Unis,
comme le montre le documentaire Take Your
Pills : Intelligence sur ordonnance (disponible
sur Netflix).
Dans Libérez votre cerveau, Idriss Aberkane
propose de retourner le problème dans l’autre
sens.
L’hypothèse qui fonde la prescription des
psychostimulants, c’est que les élèves
ne sont pas capables — en tout cas pas assez
capables d’accorder leur attention.
Et si c’était, au contraire, l’école
qui ne savait pas capter l’attention ? Et
si c’étaient le système académique et
ses méthodes qui étaient impuissants à
intéresser les élèves ?
C’est en tout cas l’avis d’Idriss Aberkane
:
« Selon moi, administrer de la ritaline à
nos enfants, sous prétexte qu’ils ne sont
pas suffisamment attentifs à l’école,
est une gigantesque erreur, par laquelle on
soigne des bien-portants, alors qu’on devrait
soigner l’école.
»
Or, vous pouvez vous aussi retourner le problème
dans l’autre sens à propos de votre culture
générale : est-ce forcément de votre faute
si vous n’arrivez pas à aller au bout du
livre que vous vous étiez juré de finir
? Est-ce vraiment parce que vous avez un déficit
de l’attention, un problème médical qui
nécessite un traitement, que vous avez presque
tout oublié de la conférence à laquelle
vous avez assisté hier ?
En fait, c’est bien de votre faute — mais
la faute n’est pas celle que vous pensez.
Vous êtes fautif parce que vous n’avez
pas appliqué le 1er secret d’Idriss Aberkane
:
STIMULER L’INTÉRÊT.
Si vous accordez votre temps et votre énergie
à des choses qui ne vous intéressent pas,
vous aurez du mal à vous concentrer ; vous
n’avancerez pas ; et vous ne retiendrez
rien.
En revanche, c’est presque sans effort que
vous développerez votre culture générale
en appliquant votre esprit à des choses qui
vous intéressent.
Alors, vous vous dites peut-être que c’est
évident.
D’accord, mais si c’est si évident, pourquoi
ne le faites-vous pas ? Pourquoi ne le faites-vous
pas autant que vous le devriez ?
Et puis j’imagine un second type d’objections
: « si je creuse uniquement les sujets qui
m’intéressent, je ne serai jamais cultivé
! » Vous vous dites que les choses qui ont
leur place dans une bonne culture générale
— disons un roman de Balzac ou un tableau
de Picasso — vous vous dites que ce genre
de choses sont forcément chiantes.
Eh bien c’est un préjugé.
Ce sont en réalité les personnes qui transmettent
les savoirs classiques qui, la plupart du
temps, les rendent chiants.
Et donc si vous voulez les intégrer pour
enrichir votre culture générale, vous devez
apprendre à stimuler votre propre intérêt.
Mais comment faire en pratique ?
Le principe est simple : vous devez faire
pour vous-même ce que quelqu’un d’autre
ferait pour capter votre attention.
Et pour trouver des techniques précises,
nous pouvons regarder…
Idriss Aberkane.
Eh bien oui, s’il y a bien une chose qu’il
sait faire, c’est capter, et conserver l’attention
des personnes auxquelles il s’adresse — à
l’écrit, et encore plus à l’oral, puisqu’il
a donné des centaines de conférences.
On ne peut pas lui reprocher de ne pas appliquer
ce qu’il prêche.
C’est grâce à son exceptionnel talent
pour stimuler l’intérêt de son auditoire
qu’il a conquis si rapidement un public
si large.
Même ses adversaires les plus virulents lui
reconnaissent cette aptitude, qui est un mélange
d’éloquence et de charisme.
Maintenant, si vous voulez stimuler votre
propre intérêt comme Idriss Aberkane stimule
celui de son audience, vous pouvez faire deux
choses.
Tout d’abord, privilégiez les histoires.
Eh oui, nous adorons les histoires ; et du
coup, présenter du savoir sous la forme du
récit du parcours d’un être humain, avec
des rebondissements, avec des dilemmes et
des émotions auxquelles nous pouvons nous
identifier — cette manière de faire est
très efficace pour stimuler l’intérêt
d’autrui comme le nôtre.
Je vous donne un exemple : si, comme moi,
vous êtes loin d’être un fan de peinture,
mais que vous souhaitez tout de même comprendre
l’apport de Picasso à l’histoire de l’art
occidental — eh bien, dans ce cas, ne vous
embarquez pas dans un essai théorique d’analyse
des œuvres de Picasso ; ne vous rendez pas
à la conférence d’un universitaire spécialiste
du peintre espagnol.
Non, contentez-vous de lire la biographie
réputée la plus vivante de Picasso.
Et de manière générale, lire des biographies
est un moyen efficace pour développer sa
culture générale.
La seconde chose que vous pouvez faire pour
stimuler votre propre intérêt comme Idriss
Aberkane stimule celui de son audience, c’est
de vous intéresser aux anecdotes.
Qu’est-ce qu’une anecdote, précisément
? C’est un fait étonnant, inédit, qui
excite notre curiosité tant il sort de l’ordinaire.
Les conférences et les livres d’Idriss
Aberkane en sont bourrés.
On peut même souvent lui faire le reproche,
sans être malhonnête, d’empiler les anecdotes
— certes bien choisies et racontées — au
détriment de l’argumentation.
Mais sur le plan de l’attention, c’est
redoutablement efficace.
À la fin des années 1980, l’entreprise
américaine Pepsi-Cola possédait des sous-marins
soviétiques (j’ai bien dit « des sous-marins
soviétiques ») : vous avez envie de décrocher
si je vous dis ça ? L’inventeur Nikola
Tesla, qui était un bel homme, a renoncé
à toute relation sexuelle : je m’arrête
de parler, ou je continue ?
Nous adorons les anecdotes.
C’est pour ça qu’elles sont une formidable
porte d’entrée vers le savoir.
Non seulement le caractère insolite du fait
capte notre attention, mais il crée aussi
une fixation dans notre mémoire — au point
que bien souvent il nous suffit d’entendre
l’anecdote une seule et unique fois pour
nous en souvenir pendant longtemps.
Ainsi, quel que soit le domaine dans lequel
vous désirez améliorer votre culture générale,
commencez par découvrir les faits étonnants.
Vous en trouverez dans les biographies, dans
des recueils d’anecdotes, dans les livres
d’Idriss Aberkane (bien sûr), et… sur
YouTube.
Connaissez-vous ce petit homme ?
Il s’agit de Vasyl Lomachenko, un boxeur
ukrainien (qui a le même âge que moi, 34
ans) — et sur cette photo, il annonce son
engagement dans l’armée pour défendre
son pays (il est même retourné en Ukraine
pour prendre les armes).
Je suis fan de ce boxeur, parce qu’il est
certainement le plus technique de tous les
temps.
Quand j’en parle à mes amis, je leur explique
que c’est comme si Peter Parker montait
sur un ring : impossible de le toucher, il
est trop rapide.
D’ailleurs, Lomachenko est tellement au
dessus du lot techniquement que ses adversaires
abandonnent de découragement, pour mettre
fin à l’humiliation (ce qui lui a valu
le surnom de Nomaschenko, à partir de l’espagnol
no mas qui signifie « pas plus, fini »).
À mes yeux, Lomachenko était évidemment
le meilleur boxeur de tous les temps…
jusqu’à ce que je trouve de solides arguments
contre cette opinion dans la vidéo d’Idriss
Aberkane sur Mohamed Ali.
Mais bon, ce débat ne vous intéresse pas.
Si je vous parle de cette vidéo, c’est
parce qu’elle m’a fait découvrir autre
chose.
En lisant la description, je suis tombé sur
les sources.
Et elles sont intéressantes à deux égards.
La 1ère chose intéressante, c’est que
pour établir sa hiérarchie des boxeurs,
Idriss Aberkane s’appuie notamment sur des
posts d’un coach de boxe, John McGlothlin,
sur le forum Quora (c’est le forum qui a
rendu célèbre Jordan Peterson).
À première vue, on se dit : des posts sur
un forum, ce n’est pas super sérieux — mais
après avoir parcouru les posts, je me suis
rendu compte que le propos du coach de boxe
est en réalité très rationnel et très
étayé.
On comprend même, à lire la description
de son profil, qu’il a « la religion du
fait ».
La 2nde chose intéressante à propos des
sources de la vidéo d’Idriss Aberkane,
c’est, comme vous vous en êtes rendu compte,
que tout cela est en anglais.
Or, en France, seule une minorité de gens
sont capables de se servir de sources en anglais
(environ un quart des Français déclaraient
maîtriser l’anglais en 2021, mais comme
il s’agit de déclarer une compétence associée
au statut social, c’est probablement moins
que ça…).
Je résume ma découverte : Idriss Aberkane
a enrichi sa culture générale en lisant
des analyses techniques en anglais non seulement
inédites, mais très qualitatives, publiées
dans les posts d’un coach de boxe américain
sur un forum.
Vous vous cultivez comme ça, vous ?
Le 2ème secret d’Idriss Aberkane, c’est
donc de MULTIPLIER LES FORMATS.
Bien sûr que vous vous cultiverez en lisant
des livres, mais ne confondez pas le contenu
et le contenant !
Comme Idriss Aberkane l’écrit dans Libérez
votre cerveau :
« La valeur d’un livre n’est pas dans
son papier mais dans ses lettres.
»
« Si vous confiez des livres, écrit Idriss
Aberkane dans L'Âge de la connaissance, de
la même taille, de la même couleur, de la
même odeur, à des chimpanzés, ils ne feront
pas de différence entre eux, parce qu’ils
verront dans les livres des objets physiques,
pas des objets immatériels, ils ne verront
pas la nuance décisive des lettres.
»
Ne soyons donc pas des chimpanzés : c’est
la connaissance qui nous importe, pas l’objet
qui la contient.
Et je dirais, encore plus fondamentalement,
c’est la connaissance qui nous importe,
pas LE FORMAT dans lequel elle est exprimée.
Or, à notre époque, le savoir est disponible
dans de multiples formats : articles et livres
bien sûr, mais aussi toutes les plateformes
où l’on peut publier du contenu écrit
(comme Quora) ; il y a également l’audio,
la vidéo.
Et enfin n’oublions pas, nous qui avons
parfois tendance, surtout depuis les confinements,
à vivre dans le digital — n’oublions
pas la transmission directe, qu’il s’agisse
du cours d’un prof ou d’une discussion
avec un ami.
Si vous vous servez dans tous les formats
disponibles, vous avez accès à un patrimoine
culturel bien plus riche — et si vous parlez
anglais, votre « buffet de connaissance », pour
parler comme Idriss Aberkane, est encore bien
plus vaste.
L’autre avantage de varier les formats,
c’est que vous vous fatiguerez moins qu’en
vous vous contentant d’un seul.
Pour passer 4 heures dans un bouquin, il faut
déjà être motivé ; mais il est moins difficile,
en 4 heures, d’ouvrir le bouquin pendant
une heure ou deux, de parcourir un forum,
de regarder une vidéo YouTube, et d’écouter
un podcast.
Maintenant, que pouvez-vous faire pour mettre
en pratique ce 2ème secret ?
Pour ce qui est de varier les formats — l’écrit,
l’audio, la vidéo, etc. — je n’ai pas
grand chose à vous dire, puisque c’est
déjà du concret.
Lorsque vous vous intéressez à un sujet
— l’histoire de la boxe, par exemple — ne
vous contentez pas du premier livre que vous
trouvez, mais cherchez la connaissance partout
où elle est disponible.
Concernant l’anglais, ensuite, si vous ne
maîtrisez pas cette langue qui est un peu
devenue la langue universelle de l’Occident,
je vous encourage très très fortement à
vous y mettre.
Si votre temps est limité, vous pouvez vous
inspirer du programme simple que j’ai suivi
pour apprendre le russe :
* une session sur l’application Duolingo
chaque jour sans exception (de préférence
le matin pour ne pas oublier) ;
* parler 2 heures par semaine (plus c’est
mieux) avec un prof (pas de grammaire ni de
théorie, uniquement une conversation amicale)
;
* écouter des podcasts (par exemple, à la
salle de sport, comme moi) ;
* regarder des séries avec les sous-titres
(pour l’anglais, vous êtes servi [tandis
que pour le russe c’était galère] !).
Enfin, il y a un outil génial pour lire en
anglais, c’est le Kindle d’Amazon.
Vous ignorez le sens d’un mot ? Posez le
doigt dessus, et vous avez la réponse.
Et cela marche aussi avec les articles que
vous trouvez sur internet et que vous envoyez
à votre Kindle.
J’insiste une dernière fois avant de passer
au secret suivant : si vous voulez avoir accès
au meilleur contenu sur à peu près n’importe
quel sujet, vous DEVEZ maîtriser l’anglais.
Croyez-vous en l’existence des anges gardiens
?
Les anges gardiens, ce sont, dans plusieurs
religions, des êtres divins de second ordre
qui, comme l’adjectif l’indique, ont pour
mission de guider et de protéger certaines
personnes.
Pas mal de fictions se sont déjà emparées
du sujet, et je m’y étais intéressé au
début de la vingtaine, après avoir écouté
le témoignage d’un homme qui prétendait
avoir échappé à un attentat dans un aéroport
grâce à son ange gardien, qui lui avait
dit — par télépathie, j’imagine — de
sortir des toilettes quelques instants avant
que la bombe n’y explose.
J’étais rapidement tombé sur le livre
de référence qui documente le phénomène,
Enquête sur l'existence des anges gardiens
de Pierre Jovanovic.
Je n’étais pas allé au bout des 500 pages,
mais j’avais découvert des histoires étonnantes,
à commencer par celle de l’auteur lui-même,
qui, en se jetant spontanément sur la gauche
sans l’avoir voulu, a miraculeusement esquivé
une balle perdue qui a pulvérisé le pare-brise
de sa voiture.
Je me souviens également du fait divers d’un
bébé indemne après une chute de plusieurs
étages.
Mais Pierre Jovanovic n’était pas très
branché paranormal avant d’échapper à
la mort.
Il était journaliste spécialisé des questions
scientifiques et technologiques au très sérieux
Quotidien de Paris.
C’est près avoir été sauvé par son ange
gardien qu’il a pris un tournant « spirituel
». Il s’est mis à écrire des livres avec
un angle original, et surtout déconcertant
pour l’homme ordinaire : pour le dire grossièrement,
il mêle la finance et le surnaturel ; il
donne des explications religieuses et spirituelles
aux phénomènes économiques.
Pourquoi vous avoir expliqué tout ça ? Quel
est le rapport avec Idriss Aberkane ?
Eh bien j’ai été étonné d’entendre
Idriss Aberkane faire référence à Pierre
Jovanovic
Je ne dis pas que c’est mal, je ne dis pas
que c’est bien ; je ne dis pas que c’est
faux, je ne dis pas que c’est vrai — je
m’étonne qu’Idriss Aberkane se serve
des idées de Pierre Jovanovic pour penser
le monde, car Jovanovic est un écrivain très
hétérodoxe — c’est le moins qu’on
puisse dire — et controversé.
Peu d’intellectuels oseraient faire référence
à ce genre d’auteurs — mais Idriss Aberkane,
lui, assume de s’intéresser à ce que dit
Jovanovic.
Idriss Aberkane lui-même a pris des positions
controversées récemment — par exemple
en doutant du résultat de l’élection américaine
— donc on pourrait croire que c’est parce
qu’il évolue dans la dissidence qu’il
assume de citer Pierre Jovanovic.
Mais la vraie raison, c’est qu’Idriss
Aberkane s’intéresse à tout le monde — peu
importe l’idéologie, la religion, le bord
politique.
La diversité des invitations auxquelles il
a répondu, la diversité des intervenants
qu’il a invités sur sa chaîne YouTube
ainsi que son idée d’une alliance entre
Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen pour battre Macron
au second tour — tout cela atteste qu’il
n’est pas l’homme d’un camp.
D’ailleurs, dans ses livres comme dans ses
vidéos, ses références sont d’une grande
variété idéologique.
Et même si ces dernières années, il faut
bien l’admettre, il s’est surtout exprimé
sur des médias et avec des personnes critiques
à l’égard des opinions dominantes, il
reste capable d’échanger avec des partisans
des opinions qu’il critique, de les écouter
— et il ne les diabolise pas.
Par exemple — si j’ai bien compris — il
est toujours animé par un sentiment de sympathie
à l’égard de Jacques Attali, qui passe
pourtant, lui, pour un des grands prêtres
de l’idéologie dominante en France (comme
le montrent d’ailleurs les commentaires
sous ma précédente vidéo, qui lui était
consacrée).
Après la multiplication des formats (qui
était le 2ème secret), le 3ème secret d’Idriss
Aberkane est donc de MULTIPLIER LES POINTS
DE VUE.
Vous voulez que votre culture générale soit
vraiment générale ? Alors refusez le dogmatisme
; acceptez de sortir de la doxa ; prenez le
risque de penser contre vous-même.
Ne cherchez pas, même si c’est le penchant
naturel de l’esprit humain, à confirmer
vos croyances ; intéressez-vous aux idées
des pensées qui vous déplaisent spontanément
— et alors vous vous rendrez peut-être
compte qu’elles ne sont pas toutes stupides…
Les opinions dominantes ne sont pas forcément
fausses ; elles ne sont pas forcément vraies
non plus — mais en vous intéressant à
d’autres opinions, même controversées,
vous vous constituez un « buffet de connaissance
» bien plus riche.
Comment faire en pratique ?
Alors, je ne vous dis pas de vous plonger
dans des manuels de théorie de la terre plate.
Vous n’avez même pas besoin d’aller aussi
loin qu’Idriss Aberkane, de vous intéresser
à des auteurs qui expliquent les mouvements
financiers à partir de la Bible.
Non, il y a plus simple : écoutez vos adversaires.
Vous pensez que les keynésiens sont de faux
économistes, des irrationalistes qui ne sont
bons qu’à balancer l’argent public par
les fenêtres ? Écoutez-les quand même ; essayez
de comprendre leur logique.
Lisez la biographie de Keynes, par exemple
— pour appliquer les deux premiers conseils
— et vous verrez que tout n’est pas à
jeter, même pour vous.
Vous pensez que les libéraux sont les prêtres
des milliardaires ? Écoutez-les quand même
; essayez de comprendre leur logique.
Lisez par exemple les Sophismes économiques
de Frédéric Bastiat, et j’espère que
vous apprécierez la justesse de certaines
idées.
Vous n’êtes pas convaincu, comme moi, que
le communisme est la solution aux malheurs
de l’humanité ? Intéressez-vous quand
même aux idées de Marx.
Et alors vous reconnaîtrez, j’espère,
que certaines de ces idées, telle l’importance
des rapports de force économiques, nous permettent
de mieux comprendre le monde.
Vous n’êtes pas convaincu, comme moi, que
le capitalisme libéral est le meilleur système
? Ne vous arrêtez pas à cette conviction,
et acceptez d’écouter les défenseurs du
capitalisme libéral.
Vous pouvez par exemple lire Capitalisme et
liberté de Milton Friedman.
Bref, sortez de votre zone de confort idéologique.
Je ne dis pas que c’est facile.
Je suis comme vous : mon sang bout lorsque
j’entends certaines choses.
Mais ce n’est pas à mieux comprendre le
monde que servent de telles réactions.
En synthèse, les trois secrets de la culture
générale d’Idriss Aberkane, ce sont de
stimuler votre propre intérêt, de multiplier
les formats, et de multiplier les points de
vue.
Si vous mettez en pratique ces secrets, vous
vous cultiverez bien plus efficacement.
Voilà voilà, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu, et puis qu’elle vous sera utile.
Si c’est le cas, donnez-lui un pouce bleu,
et puis laissez un commentaire, pour améliorer
le référencement de la vidéo — ce n’est
pas grand chose, et ça m’aide vraiment.
Vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
J’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
Croyez-moi :
faites-le,
et vous me remercierez.